time goes by and just as soon as we
enter 2023 full of optimism it's time to
bid goodbye but it's not all nostalgic
longing when we have a bright year ahead
of us in the world of anime with 2024
just around the corner I'm already
seeing a couple of really cool shows to
watch out for when the calendar rolls
through another year here let me
introduce you to some of
them opening things up is The Unwanted
Undead adventurer
coming back stronger is a theme in anime
and the whole weak to strong thing won't
appear on this list just once for now
though let's talk about the less
heralded one between the two titles
unwanted Undead Adventurer starts off
following Plucky Adventurer rent who
bites off a bit more than he can chew
instead of finding treasure at the end
of a path he meets a sudden demise
courtesy of a dragon fortunately that's
not the end of him remaining as a pile
of bones he readies his equipment and
sets off on his new quest for evolution
one that will end up with him returning
to his old glorious form really getting
some berserk of gluttony Vibes with the
character design here and I'm sure that
those of you who enjoy the darker side
of fantasy anime will enjoy this one do
take note though it's not exactly arura
like in that the main character is
overpowered and being reborn from his
first death so to
speak and number nine is Tales of
wedding
[Music]
rings okay so I'm not going to lie I
didn't know what to expect out of this
one at first you know the premise is of
our main protagonist Sato finally
getting the chance to confess to his
best friend hee in classic anime fashion
nothing goes according to plan and the
two are instead transported to another
world sure saur gets his wish as he may
chooses him to be her groom but it can't
comes with the responsibility of
defeating the Demon Lord in this world
using girls as his power source Q sudden
isekai Haram an adaptation of a manga
that started all the way back in 2014
Tales of wedding rings pretty much ticks
the boxes of what people liked about
isaki and Haram titles some fan service
a whole bunch of comedy and a pretty
enjoyable plot All Things Considered
it's not exactly a masterpiece but it's
serviceable if you're into that
[Music]
genre
we're not ready to leave fantasy land
yet because our next entry is the witch
and the
Beast in contrast to the previous title
this is a more serious type of fantasy
anime here which is plague the world
casting curses that are n impossible to
remove standing against them are members
of the order of magical resonance an
organization that deals with with cases
involving Magic on the trail of witch
the two agents cat eyed gido and the
stoic Asaf appear in a town however this
is no ordinary town for this is a place
where witch has completely enthralled
its citizens convincing them she's a
hero the two had tussles with witches
before and they smelled something fishy
what thrilling secrets and Revelations
await the two as they dive deep into
this case we'll find out once the show
airs this winter it's surely something
that I'm looking forward
[Music]
to
[Applause]
[Music]
my instant death ability is so
overpowered no one in this other world
stands a chance against me is the next
anime on the
list
sh we've seen overpowered protagonists
before and there are dime a dozen but I
are you ready to take that theme to
another level to take it to the extreme
here we have an isekai protagonist who
has the ability get this instant death
yeah it doesn't matter that he missed
out on Powers or that he and one lone
companion get abandoned to their Doom
with the power of instant death not even
the strongest monsters stand a chance
against him however that ability of his
does open the doors to a lot of intrigue
will he use the power of instant death
to save the world or is he too sleepy
and apathetic to even care I have to say
giving a rather apathetic character such
a crazy power in an isaki does make for
some unpredictable moments yeah there's
not much challenge in terms of actual
combat but how he makes use of the power
interests me also there are problems you
just can't Brute Force out of and it's
something I look forward to seeing our
protagonist tackle pretty wild isai that
some people will love I'm
[Music]
sure for the next anime on the list we
have metallic
[Music]
Rouge with all the fantasy titles we've
covered so far how about time for some
sci-fi a commemorative one as Studio
bones is set to celebrate 25 years
actually and they couldn't have picked a
better genre the action seems to be the
studio strong suit with hits like FMA my
hero Academia and others blending sci-fi
and magical powers has proven to yield
good results with stuff like sfog gear
and I've got some high hopes for this
anime after all in addition to zle gear
I've likeed tiger and Bunny and that's
the Vibes that the trailer is giving me
bones has had a great run so far and
this will likely be another good
original anime they can add under their
belt as far as we can see for now the
production values for this one are going
to be good great visuals and nice sound
Direction don't make an anime but it is
a
start
don't forget to hit that like button if
you found a show to watch so far if not
don't worry we've got five more new
anime coming out that might just be the
one you're looking for let's relax a bit
with this next title shall we a sign of
[Music]
affection here's the seasonal pick for
Comfort anime a sign of affection comes
to us with a not quite reminiscent of
something you can see from a theatrical
production you have the disabled
protagonist the chance meeting that
brings renewed hope to her life and the
growing relationship and budding romance
with characters that are easy to root
for and some visuals that might as well
be on par with anime movies this could
be a sleeper hit for winter at least a
reasonably strong candidate for best
romance 2 while it may not end up
becoming a mainstream hit that people
will get hyped for week after week this
is my top recommendation if you want
something light and touching it's the
perfect Escape for people who find
everyday life life rather stressful
here's some hope and positivity for you
we all need that in life don't
[Music]
we turn we move on with an action title
next there's only so much you can do
with the setting of a world inhabited by
humans and monsters that live amongst
them to make the whole product feel
original you can shake things up a
little bit with the twists in the world
or the character Dynamics yes but
nothing hardly stands out anymore these
days does it here you have a monster
protagonist teaming up with a human hero
who utterly despises humans it sure
makes for an entertaining Duo to follow
as they go on their Adventures learning
more about the truth of the world still
not that unique don't you think Soko
Yoko however exhibits its strength in
how it handles the buildup to the plot
it's a title that really feels
incomplete if you've only seen the first
few parts luckily the anime has been
granted a generous number of episodes
that can help facilitate this with so
much stock being placed on the buildup
and the twist that come pretty late it
ends up being a curious choice for a
fantasy action series but it's a bold
decision that some people would
like for the third ranked title on the
list we have have chained
soldier ever wonder what the guys behind
aami GA killer up to these days well
here's your answer a glance at the art
in the key visuals is all you need to
evoke memories of one of the big hits
from the mid-2010s however chain Soldier
pushes the envelope further with the
crazy fan service in Haram Shenanigans
giving us what seemed to be a way more
unrestrained take on the whole secret
organizations fighting monsters premise
people from back then have come to love
this time we've got more degeneracy and
more intense fights under our belt given
the author's track record with akami
kill I can't say I'm surprised in the
slightest chain Soldier is not all about
the NSFW though as some of the fights
can be legitimately unironically
entertaining and engaging I can't wait
to see how this one's going to turn
out delicious IND dungeon is also coming
this winter giving us a much needed wine
down phase from the intensity of the
past few
[Music]
entries give me a concept an idea that's
been done before and I'll make gold out
of it that seems to be what the
Creator's going with in delicious in
Dungeon the idea of eating monsters
isn't anything new nor is the whole
sword and sorcery setting that
characterizes this title however
delicious in Dungeon shows that it all
comes down to execution as this is a
title that makes quite a mundane concept
into a very creative an engaging story
to follow comedy is King in this title
but let's not forget the actual drawer
of the show The Monster dishes it's food
anime at its peak and it meshes so well
with the lovable characters in their own
stories of growth if you want a
lightharted series that's wholesome with
a lot of fantasy elements thrown in
there there's no better time to start
getting into anime than now this title
truly deserves its
popularity
solo leveling is here to finish off this
list there's no contest that amongst the
new anime coming this winter 2024 solo
leveling is the one that everyone's been
anticipating the most the hype from the
community is real and aniplex is more
than ready to cash in on this cultural
phenom phenomenum as for the story
itself well it tells of a world where
Hunters battle monsters with our
protagonist here being a weakling who
Rises against the world and becomes
stronger looking to eventually become
the most powerful Hunter of the more a
tried and true formula that's garnered
quite a lot of success and adding the
whole Underdog appeal and the gritty
dark atmosphere that's the icing on the
cake why do you think we have two new
anime on this list that do the whole
fighting monsters underneath a dark
backdrop thing solo leveling is primed
to be the breakout hit of winter 2024
and the whole world is watching in sheer
anticipation whether it will rise
through the ranks or flounder is
anyone's guess personally I'm hoping
that the badass moments from The Source
material as well as the amazing
expressiveness of the art managed to
translate really well to anime
formats and That Just About Does it 202
24 already looks to have a great start
doesn't it on the other hand what are
your pics please share your thoughts
down below well that's a wrap thank you
for watching and I hope you'll be here
for the next seasonal video Stay awesome
and take care out there